justamente es hora de conectar con la
red de corresponsales de france 24 en
directo a hoy vamos a washington pese a
que sólo hasta principios de julio se
espera que la corte suprema de eeuu se
pronuncie sobre el derecho al aborto a
nivel federal este lunes se filtró un
borrador del tribunal que indica que los
jueces van a anular la histórica e
icónica sentencia del caso roe versus
wade que es justamente la que protege el
derecho de las mujeres a interrumpir el
embarazo conectamos con cristóbal
vázquez corresponsal de france 24
cristóbal cómo queda la situación en la
corte con esta filtración y cómo queda
la situación para las mujeres en eeuu
con una decisión tan radical
si hay que mencionar que la corte
suprema de justicia confirmó que esta
información era verídica esta
información que filtró el medio político
el lunes por la noche este documento de
98 páginas era un texto que había
escrito el juez samuel alito y alegaba
que el aborto no estaba en la
constitución de eeuu sin embargo fue un
texto que fue escrito el 10 de febrero y
no es un borrador final es decir los
argumentos ahí pueden cambiar como
también puede cambiar la mayoría de 5 a
4 magistrados de la corte suprema de
justicia que apoyarían entonces pues la
medida contra el aborto de eeuu que
pondría en riesgo a muchas mujeres de
este país uno de los riesgos iniciales
sería por ejemplo el tema de la
migración de la migración de mujeres que
quieren practicar el aborto en estados
donde no sería posible a estados donde
sí sería posible esto implica altos
costos para las mujeres y pues no todas
y no todas las familias o las mujeres
están en capacidad de hacerlo también el
tema de las clínicas clandestinas
es bastante importante porque se han
reportado pues varias muertes en estas
prácticas en clínicas clandestinas en el
aborto justamente hoy oklahoma prohíbe
el aborto desde la semana 6 de embarazo
cada vez son más los estados que
aprueban restricciones cómo podría
quedar el panorama de la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo si consideramos
que los gobiernos estatales republicanos
son los que están impulsando estas
normativas restrictivas
la mayoría de los estados son
republicanos son estados del sur y se
calcula que son alrededor de 26 estados
26 de los 50 estados que tiene este país
es decir más de la mitad de los estados
empezaría a restringir el aborto
suspenderlo también en algunos casos
sería el panorama que empezaría a verse
en eeuu si esto ocurre después de que se
tome la decisión es paradójico y muchos
analistas dicen que es paradójico el
tema de que sean los republicanos los
que tratan de bloquear ayudas a las
familias ayudas a las guarderías para
los niños ayudas para la salud para la
educación de los niños pero al mismo
tiempo son los que también están
empujando la agenda para que las madres
no puedan tener y no puedan abortar
teniendo en cuenta además los altos
precios de la salud de este país
obviamente muchas organizaciones y
activistas salieron a las calles hoy y
van a seguir los próximos días
manifestando la libertad de escoger de
la mujer con el tema del aborto es
bastante paradójica esta posición de los
republicanos ya lo decía cristóbal
muchas gracias por esta ampliación ya